did you guys see joe rogan with sanjay
gupta yesterday yeah yes you see that
collection that was he really good
which he never does yeah he went on the
offensive for maybe i've been listening
to rogan for five years yeah i've never
seen him go on the offensive line that
was impressive the way he asked the
question he said so do you feel at risk
when you go out and you know do your
thing and do play you know live your
life just no because i'm vaccinated it
says great he says you being vaccinated
have the same amount of risk as a kid
that's not vaccinated but why are we
forcing kids to be vaccinated because
out of millions of kids only 500 kids
have died
and so you have the same ratio risk why
would we force the kids to get
vaccinated and he didn't have an answer
he was stuck because you know in
california
for getting out there taking the tough
questions he he felt like
joe at the beginning of the interview is
like how do you feel working for a
network that lies look yeah and and to
group those credit he's like yeah they
they shouldn't have said that and then
joe pressed them and pressed them and
they wouldn't admit that they lied
something that you say all the time is
like something that's
that's a liable mission something that
trump does is he'll get on
opposite polarizing views and still
state his case so yeah you've got to
give it a thing
if you go on okay i get that but if you
go on opposing platforms and still lie
on those platforms you don't get it
it's a liable mission it's very simple
did they lie about in vermectin well no
no well did well no that's not true he
says no he owned up to they said they
shouldn't have said that yeah
but then he refused to talk about what's
it feel like about the network he
refused to talk about the network
consistently lying he could he refused
yeah that's a tough situation to be in
he's not that's that's he's not the
voice
but
the whole thing would line the whole
thing with lines cnn line yesterday uh
uh van jones flat out i don't know if
you guys saw van jones yesterday or not
i'm a fan of ann jones as well although
van jones was a card-carrying you know
communist years ago and all this stuff
you know when he was first linked to
obama they had to pull them out and say
hey we can't affiliate with you banjo
yesterday said listen the honeymoon is
over biden's getting crushed okay and if
they continue this way it's not going to
happen he says the republican is united
republican parties united right now with
congress every one of them voted the
same way they just said that not a
single republican voted against the uh
what do you call what it
that ceiling he says but the democrats
are in shambles right now okay and and
if they go the way they're going right
now it's not going to be a good uh
midterms it's not going to be this he
says they have 12 months to fix it but
then chris cuomo said the following
chris cuomo said he said van it doesn't
matter anyways because even if you guys
go there the opposing party is willing
to lie to your face just to get
re-elected they're willing to compromise
the democracy of america and evangelism
the balls that's chris cohen was saying
that so so the point is on one and on
the same exact day when rogan comes out
with gupta saying yeah you know they
should have said that the network lied
same day cuomo was saying everybody on
the other side lies so you know to be
fair we could go on to fox news and find
all the lies
there is do you okay this has got
nothing to do with the left or the right
this has got to do with the fact that
one says the other doesn't end the other
doesn't we don't that's the problem it's
like no no no we don't do it we're holy
but they do it no both of you have done
it and both of you have a hard time
coming out and saying i'm sorry we
screwed up so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]